and I also think the other perfor like
Keke Palmer from Akeelah and the bee
which by the way I was the extra in it
have sat right next to her slow down
that film you'll notice a really young
lad named Gregory Alba they're doing
background work yeah since then I
haven't gone on to do better things in
my life what's up reject nation of Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey we're gonna talk
about the highly rated hustlers today
starring a bunch of fine-ass ladies John
and I went together sat next to each
other and were like I'm so hot now yeah
did you know you went to go watch it
till this morning I saw last night with
my girlfriend
I saw it alone sawed alone sat in the
dark corner weird at all I heard about
this movie a few months ago primarily as
a movie the heck Hardie be in it and my
girlfriend's obsessed with Hardy B if
that's the reason you're going
yeah she's barely she's great when she's
in it she I think she's wonderful awake
hilarious when she's in it when I first
heard about this I saw like a minute of
the trailer on Twitter and like dad this
is look like my kind of movie and by the
way if you're in a relationship and your
girlfriend's obsessed with cardi B it's
a great way to keep you on edge that you
were constantly messing up or that she's
gonna suspect you of being unfaithful
always like what do you think of me and
then I saw all these like great reviews
and I was like you know what this sounds
interesting yeah let's go watch this
movie I really liked it barely
remembered anything I saw bit I really
didn't know what the movie was about
going and from my understanding you
literally knew nothing about except
rákóczi C star over there and so I could
gather it was probably about crime and
strippers and it had all these people
yeah that's pretty much what I thought
too I would quite enjoyed this movie I
thought it was a lot of fun I thought it
was really entertaining it's inspired by
this true story I read the article that
it's based off of and I didn't know any
of that going in I didn't know this was
even inspired by a true story it starts
off before the economic crisis I had a
feeling it would deal with it only
because Gary Sanchez productions showed
up you know that's Adam Cain Wilfred
loved dealing with his topic
yes movie reminded me of a lot of movies
and part with
I was like I was thinking of the big
short and then at the end I saw they
produced no it was like oh there we yeah
yeah it takes place before that and it's
about these strippers who essentially
would make a bunch of money primarily
hustling a strippers through the wolfes
of Wall Street so then eventually
there's the economic downfall crisis and
then what the main story the main thing
that the article was covering like the
big hook of this is what these strippers
decided to do to make up for the fact
that their clientele could no longer
keep throwing thousands upon thousands
of dollars in them six nights a week
which involved a lot of drugging them
and stealing from them it's a really
fascinating weird story that is heavily
inspired in the style of Martin Scorsese
films yeah I kept flashing you know like
the the films of his like Goodfellas
Casino wolf of wallstreet because
they've been emulated by many directors
so it's not something I watch and I go
for a lot of direct will already kind of
mirrored that kind of style
I feel like Wall Street in general just
has its own tone that like cinema just
mandated it it has a good structure I
thought because of the fact of how
you're really living in the lives of
primarily Constance Wu and Jennifer
Lopez these two characters are
essentially the heart the main
characters the focus of the story when
you're watching their rise and power
that did have a thought there was a
slight portion of this film a very very
slight where I got a little bit bored
because the start getting repetitive
only cuz there's a long portion of this
versus suit like it's going incredibly
well for them for like an hour straight
thing is you start to think you're
reminded of Goodfellas I thought the
structure was a bit odd because of that
because there's also they kind of a
scene I jump over 12 years and it seems
like it probably needed a two-and-a-half
hour runtime that's a film that I think
could have definitely used the runtime
of the films it's inspired by for those
reasons especially because yeah it does
create this lopsided experience we're
like the good half of Goodfellas is like
most of the movie and then the downfall
is kind of on the end yeah it's not even
a huge down but what I thought would the
structure of how they they interwove it
nicely was because they cut back and
forth between the interview at Constance
Woo's character which was the primary
drive of that article they keep
reminding you like don't worry
consequences are coming even though it's
all fun consequences will come but there
was a point where I was like where's the
where's like the tension
yeah it's some of these situations it
seems like it's just going great but
even in that point you know that was
very slight when I was a little bit
pulled out because even not even my
expectations during the actual plot but
even for most of it I thought it was a
total blast everyone's raving about it
one of the primary reasons I want her to
go check it out everyone's talking about
it
Jennifer Lopez Oh scene stealer in this
movie you know this reminded me a lot of
good fellows in the way of how that was
really ray Liotta's movie but everyone
talks about the other and this is more
Constance Woo's movie she's the main
character if anything Jennifer Lopez is
the main supporting or at least equal
lead to in this film because a lot of
the way Jennifer Lopez's character is
portrayed as seen through the lens of
Constance Woo's character she's like
mentored kind of has this sort of mother
point of view towards Jennifer Lopez's
character she takes her she takes
Constance Wu yang and really helps her
they find her see less
JLo is like top stripper and I saw that
there was a trending I didn't watch the
video I just get to the good stuff in
the video there is this trending video
of like JLo learning how to strip for
this movie the pole dancing JLo is like
big scene she's the only actress who
really gets a cool like pole dancing
scene in this movie which she does that
dance I think every one of my theater
started talking like everyone because
it's an amazing how she looks incredible
like she's she's much older than when I
was a kid she's she's aged yet it
doesn't show she's got like this
top-notch body her physicality like is
she's so skilled it reminded me of the
first time I went to a strip club
first of I think 1098 I went to the
first time I descript was only a few
years ago actually I remembered thinking
when I went to the strip club like oh it
was gonna be hot gonna be a bunch of
naked chicks be so cool so excited so
turned on and then I went to this true
Club and universes pulled
singing I was like yo this is a really
difficult miring just how yeah and
impressive the actual act of the dance I
don't actually get this I didn't get lap
dances or anything I wasn't turned on I
was just watching it going this is this
is very difficult I'm not good there's
no way I could do that and that's kind
of what JLo's dance reminded me of but
this is insanely impressive how she does
it but beyond the dancing just as a
performer in this film the phrase
commands the screen really comes to mind
for me for her performance I can see why
people are raving so much about her that
being said though I'm kind of surprised
that no one's really mentioning
Constance whoo
I think Constance Wu is awesome in this
movie I'd loved her performance I think
some people have been a little bit mixed
on her portrayal I am you are okay yes
Olivia yeah but I I was I walked out
really thinking she gave a very good
vulnerable for poor performance because
of the pacing of this film sometimes the
pacing the editing is a little bit off
and then there are times where I did
kind of wish we could gotta get a little
bit more into the psychology of the
characters that's the major thrust of my
trouble with the movie overall is like I
feel what kept me from from knowing
Constance Wu is an issue of just yeah we
don't really get intimate with any of
our main characters we see details about
their lives like Constance well as a kid
she's going to school in one point but
we don't really see beneath the surface
or spend much time in the environment of
what their lives are like and so I
didn't really feel like I knew her until
a tiny info-dump at the very end that
expounded upon her life
like she's the audience cypher she's how
we are getting into the stripclub world
in this movie and also for a lot of
people who this is not their normal
environment she is how we're going to
sink into this world it was hard to kind
of latch on to her as a human Oh see I
completely disagree because I felt
Constance Wu brought that in her
performance I thought everybody else did
because of the the limited runtime on
this movie I thought that you know
because of writing and directing date
they couldn't fully capture that but I
thought were ever that lacked I thought
the performers would JLo and Constance
Wu I thought they really provided that I
did feel connected to Constance whose
character
throughout this whole film like this
very young vulnerable her motivation I I
do have to disagree that I do I do feel
like we did get to know her pretty well
through how she reacted her response is
sometimes when they're doing these time
jumps and was a little fast at this
whole thing with her boyfriend I was
like wait what what's happened weather
well what's going on with her boyfriend
she has a boyfriend
and now what the hell is she easy I
always understood why she kept doing it
but I never understood why she actually
got into stripping I believed her half
the time and there are other times worse
there was just something and I don't
know what it is so it's not a hundred
percent of fair criticism I guess I
thought everybody else on the screen had
enough sort of life and mannerism to
their performance that I just believed
it's like if this movie had centered
around JLo instead I think in this form
I might have not been pulled out as many
times now like what this movie does in
terms of how it treats its subjects it
is very empowering I would imagine
embrace sexuality but also shows these
women as enterprising confident smart
sharp yeah and it puts them against an
interesting moral situation where you
have these bad pretty bad dudes who they
yeah that's what I loved about it those
yeah yeah a lot of times I think there's
like good fellows in Wall Street well
for Wall Street you're like man these
main characters are awful humans but
then with this movie like there are
times where they do such a couple of
characters where you're like but for the
most part I was like the same time like
everyone yeah I do have to think that I
I sympathize so much for for sex workers
in general because it's a part of life
that is not well accepted and is also
out imagine hard to get people to want
to pay for and so for women in their
profession especially I love that
juxtaposition to of the market crash
then all these women are out of work
yeah and it's already hard enough I
would imagine for them to make good
money and to get to that point so you do
really sympathize with what they're
doing and who they're doing it to
despite the great there's a fascinating
portion in that film where the economic
crash happened I was like wow even
strippers were affected by this yeah and
so fasten thats a fascinating concept to
me and i think this film does have that
glossy paint about it it's got this like
gorgeous
monography and some awesome sound
editing - there's there's a couple of
scenes especially I don't want to give
it away there's a scene in the last half
of the movie I'll just say that where
they did something really unique with a
sound design choice that I thought made
this one scene I think by saying that
you'll notice it heywhat because when
they did I was like oh that's a really
different way to do this scene and we
especially when we're moving kind of
fast right now to make this scene very
engaging and heighten the tension of
this moment but keke palmer has some of
the funniest lines this movie oh she's a
stereo yeah Lily Reinhart was good - she
doesn't get to be much of a character
[ __ ] you said about constant rooms like
I kind of felt that way about her one of
the things that impressed me most about
this movie that was just the direction
because of all the movies I've seen
lately that are inspired by other films
and that are very stylized I thought
this had a very keen use of style and
when it would shift and use yeah for
visual you know motifs and whatnot I
thought they were all really appropriate
and really keenly chosen yeah and that's
great for a movie like this that rides
so much on energy and life and
especially like when you're in the club
you really feel like you're there with
these women what it's like behind the
scenes yeah yeah and I think that's
arguably the best thing about this movie
is that it just shows you a side of the
world that you know people aren't as
used to it's weird yeah if you just gave
this movie a little more time I thought
of CAM while I was watching this and
ironically one of the strippers is
played by the lead in cam and what cam
does I think ultimately better than this
film is it really gets into the
psychology of what her actual life is
like I think if this movie had that it
could be kind of perfect as it stands
though it's like I kind of got
disoriented with some of the character
things because I wasn't familiar with
anything going in yeah so it felt kind
of lopsided but overall yeah there's a
lot of great acting a lot of great you
know energy a lot of great filmmaking on
display
maybe the script could have had more
life to it is all I would say yeah
whatever these wants that I feel like we
had from it I don't feel as passionate
of like I really wish this movie had
that because I did feel the performers
ultimately made up for whatever that was
like I would probably give this like
like
3.8 five out of five for some that's
probably what I get yeah I would say
watch a review now from a woman or a
person of color only watch what the men
think about this movie blaka nudity well
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell if you enjoyed our video you guys
can check sound patron or do weekly q
and A's TV show reactions stream along
some with reaction highlights included
and before we wrap this up let's give a
patron the day shout out specifically
chose a woman for this one because it's
hustlers a lot of ladies in here men
suck your cash at LBL
my dear you're constantly sending this
really positive kind message is always
looking out giving homeboy here a bunch
of BTS requests and they're always
interactive with us I decided to look up
your name how could it not have been
more perfect for this shout out your
name literally means she so with that in
mind keep being a woman stay strong as a
woman strip if you must but also don't
let men take advantage of you if there's
one thing hustlers taught me is that all
men suck in our perks and you must keep
true to your your female self I know how
to speak for n to women obvious
definitely yeah yeah so on that pronoun
sister Christian do your thing
she like and serve mana Shetty God
satire is not a real thing